the investigation into the explosion at
liverpool women's hospital led by
counter-terrorism policing
is continuing at pace
the circumstances as we understand them
to be now that yesterday
shortly before 11am a local taxi driver
picked up a fair in the rutland avenue
area of liverpool
the fair a man
had asked to be taken to liverpool
women's hospital which was about 10
minutes away
as the taxi approached the drop-off
point at the hospital an explosion
occurred from within the car
this quickly engulfed it in flames
remarkably the taxi driver escaped from
the cab
he's been treated for his injuries that
he sustained and he's now been released
from hospital
emergency services quickly attended the
scene and merseyside fire and rescue
extinguished the flames
it quickly became apparent then that the
passenger remained in the vehicle and
was deceased
army ordnance disposal officers have
examined the scene at the hospital and
made the area safe
following discussions with army ordnance
disposal we are able to confirm
that this is being treated as the
ignition of an explosive device
our inquiries also indicate that the
device was brought into the cab
by the passenger
we believe we know the identity of the
passenger but we cannot confirm this at
this time
our enquiries have led us to two
addresses
the first was suclift street in the
kensington area of liverpool and at this
location three men aged 21 26 and 29
were arrested yesterday under section 41
of the terrorism act
a short while ago
again in the kensington area a further
man age 20 was arrested under section 41
of the terrorism act
they will be interviewed later today by
counter-terrorism detectives
the sutcliffe street address was
searched overnight and further searches
will take place today
a second address has also been searched
at rutland avenue in sefton park
at this location
significant items have been found
further searches will be necessary today
and potentially into the coming days
a cordon is in place at this location
and eight families have been evacuated
at this time
the scene at the hospital remains in
place with specialist examinations
ongoing
it is not clear what the motivation for
this incident is
our inquiries indicate that an
improvised explosive device has been
manufactured
and our assumption so far is that it was
built by the passenger in the taxi
the reason why he then took it to the
women's hospital is unknown
as is the reason for its sudden
explosion
we are of course aware that there were
remembrance events just a short distance
away from the hospital and that the
ignition occurred shortly before 11am
we cannot at this time draw any
connection with this but it is a line of
inquiry which we are pursuing
although the motivation for this
incident is yet to be understood
given all the circumstances it has been
declared a terrorist incident and
counter-terrorism policing are
continuing with the investigation
our inquiries will now continue to seek
to understand how the device was built
the motivation for the incident and to
understand if anybody else was involved
in it thank you
i completely understand that communities
in merseyside may be concerned
i can reassure you that my officers are
out and about on the ground providing
high visibility reassurance
there is no specific threat to the area
but i have asked for patrols to be
increased right across merseyside
incidents such as this are very rare
but i would ask people to remain calm
but also be vigilant and alert
there has also been lots of speculation
on social media and false reports of
further incidents
for that reason i would urge members of
the public to rely on official
information which will be released on
our twitter feed at mersey police
and the merseyside police website for
information or at gmp police
the people of liverpool and merseyside
are well known for supporting each other
and at a time like this this is needed
more than ever
offices from counter-terrorism policing
north west are leading the investigation
supported by officers and staff from
merseyside police
and we are continuing to work with our
partners of merseyside fire and rescue
service and the liverpool women's
hospital to establish what has taken
place
merseyside police will continue to
liaise with community groups
community leaders partner agencies and
individuals in the coming days and weeks
to make sure that any concerns are
addressed and ensuring that we provide
the best possible service to our people
here in merseyside
it is also important that people do not
speculate about what has happened but we
will endeavor to update our communities
as soon as we are able
i would continue to advise people to be
vigilant and if they have any concerns
to contact the police on 101 or 999 in
an emergency
thank you